na tua será a unidade da mabe a mãe da
menina na área de guina até final da rua
na área e aí nada de irregular
mas o ponto da lei é mocinho
ninguém tem desculpa a tam ainda estamos
nesse ponto e costa
mas fato day abalo longo
juan logo amor é importante por simon o
do pão e da troca de chã onde nasceu o
jazz o normal ora guiou a semana
gum machucado no centro de ulan falou-me
rio
o lançou o álbum bons que mexi hoje a
lua o time é ouvi lo lembra pouco com
douto libras chute ro gay recherche
en los baixou em blow job universo
rasgou-lhe one esboço chico a hoje
em laranja distância dela faz o bom
humor los nem gente e ninguém no banco
lan é a mensagem ainda falou e beijo não
falou nada mudará
se a mídia é isso forró waugh longe da
diana é uma onda de frio nos dos dois
tanto em quem anda gostando e sai em céu
assim meu sangue erro
hans rasgante o baseball ó los da os
dois pulsos tender well 15 times a
estrela de william
o foguete tipo no futuro tanto de em pó
nos dois estudos
não gostei
vamos anotar as chances o time de roma
ele professa nem site inb saída em meio
rodrigão e dante com quem a bicão
muito quanto reflecte bem fora da cruz
popular
alô los com a peixe brasil
solla que têm da língua ou de joan anda
pedestre o odair wharton orlas dos tudo
bem
não vai ser em fez lo a messi dá lhe ô
diante do golden glory que você chorou
nós mercinho gatil diante de shopping
de lojas e daí sair falou nós dois o
tutti
não fala aí na mãe
hoje quando muda a lecce
o times tanto on the run for que
formular nós donos da di-all habitué do
dm los do swat de assim esgotadas 11
falou desafio ao rio ea loja ganhou em
memphis
ainda tinha em sua de maidan banants
frio a chuva ou o tal lance o time de
novo com do sub
ando gudes quanto bay é e sim de pé da
paz às drogas
o bem ao golo de ruben amorim
ando dos a
não valeu nem o lazio roma da área jéci
onde o tinha sogas day deu fé elenco viu
del ferro e odeia lo los da paz foi o
play em país com de vivências de em i
love to say i love you nós vamos porque
está em pé
[Silence]
nesse texto da fai é este o ons lo nos
dois cua jazz
nesta altura só para outra olha as aulas
dos riscos a lei
ué lançou the beauty of chun o zob ahan
sesi o time é o mesmo desafio
de dez em dez dias ou horas de hoje na
área de aids dessa de hoje
rio dona cilene incisivo do sítio
o marca os ferros lo do milan
o projeto de orlov
por mim sorriu apenas adoro os filmes do
[Arabic recitation]
terminar a menina esteja ali uma forma
ruim no clube
na primeira fissura olha aí o treino a
vale estando o ataque está na hora então
axixá povo somali o animal ouve se o
túnel afp
naquela linha operada em mim loooool ele
na bahia não é real
o programa da krona fez nada e única
então ter forró y ea funcionário da
usina na final nova versão está
atendendo por lá foi na área deixando a
única em oitavo e aí outro lado
apresentada pelo menino
nossa missão na terra